سهيب ما الذي يحدث في الجبهه الشماليه في
جنوب لبنان الجبهه الشماليه حتى هذه
اللحظه قاعده الاشتباك على ما هي عليه بين
اسرائيل وحزب الله القصف بالقصف وهذه
القاعده
مازالت يعني تتصاعد شيئا فشيئا ولكنها لم
تفلت عن قاعده الاشتباك هذه بين الحزب
واسرائيل ولكن هناك شكل اخر من القتال على
الجبهه الشماليه وهو صواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه كتائب القسام التي اطلقتها من
هناك والكتائب اعلنت في اكثر من مناسبه
انها اطلقت قد وصواريخ باتجاه المدن
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه اخر الوصول
لصواريخ القسام من لبنان كانت مدينه
نهاريه التي تبعد حوالي 10 م م عن الحدود
بين لبنان واسرائيل اذا نتحدث عن شكلين من
القتال هناك شكل بين حزب الله واسرائيل
الذي يتخذ قصف ضربات من الحزب للنقاط
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في المناطق التي
تحتلها اسرائيل في جنوب لبنان وقصف
الصواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحديدا
كتائب القسام انطلاقا من جنوب لبنان نحو
اسرائيل هذا الامر اد الى قرار اسرائيلي
باخلاء حوالي 30 مستوطنه على شريط الحدودي
بين لبنان واسرائيل بعمق 5 م م هذا الامر
لم يحصل منذ سنوات ابرز هذه المستوطنات
مستوطنه كريات شموه الليي يسكنها حوالي
25000 مستوطن قرر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اخلاءها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اليوم كان
في الجبهه الشماليه وقال لجنوده بان حزب
الله قرر الدخول في هذه المواجهه وانه
سيدفع ثمن هذا القرار ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
لم نسمع تصريحا من حز بالله بالدخول في
هذه المواجهه وفتح جبهه جديده على اسرائيل
بموازاه جبهه قطاع غزه الاعين كلها الان
نحو الجبهه الشماليه لانه حزب الله اذا ما
قرر الدخول في هذه المواجهه فهذا يعني
جبهه ستكون عنيفه للغايه وان الحرب ستتخذ
نطاقا اوسع بكثير اذا ما اخذنا بالاعتبار
القدرات العسكريه الهائله لحزب الله
مقارنه بالقدرات العسكريه لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه